you see there's somebody who wants to
meet you
you don't know him no but you took his
name
and now he wants it back
no sorry i still don't get it it
is western sydney home to the newest
edition of the marvel movie franchise
the seven news chopper captured these
scenes today as work resume building the
set for the upcoming production
shang chi and the legend of the ten
rings it's understood
that all cast and crew have now arrived
from overseas
and after completing their required
quarantine shooting will begin
in the coming days 18 weeks later than
originally planned welcome back everyone
it's charlie so we have a brand new
marvel shang chi clip to break down
there's a whole bunch of stuff going on
with the movie because marvel's starting
to film all their movies again
thankfully things are getting going so
we'll break it all down there's a bunch
of easter eggs
if you're new to the channel be sure to
subscribe to get all the videos
we're doing an amazon giveaway all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and let me know what you want them to do
with the shang chi
character in marvel phase four so the
new marvel clip and the new scenes that
they dropped here just part of their
real
mcu mandarin story the fact that it's a
traditional asian village with no signs
of modern technology
probably means that it's most likely for
flashback scenes explaining the origin
story of the real mandarin in his rise
to power in his quest to acquire the ten
rings of power
and then forming the actual 10 rings
organization that we've seen in all the
iron man movies
there been a lot of jokes in the iron
man movies about the 10 rings themselves
are they real are they not real
the movie itself will actually canonize
the actual comic book 10 rings they are
real and they'll be trying to find them
through the course of the film but that
just implies that at the beginning of
the movie the mandarin doesn't actually
possess
all 10 of them maybe he has a couple of
them but if you're not really familiar
with the character shang chi himself
as a character was created to be
marvel's bruce lee basically
he debuted in the comics in 1973 during
the big
marvel kung fu craze that was sweeping
pop culture at the time thanks to people
like bruce lee in real life
be formless shadeless
like water 1973 is also the same year
that they released bruce lee's enter the
dragon so no coincidence there
the shanxi movie is designed to be like
marvel's version of enter the dragon but
with an actual
real dragon like fing fang fume in the
movie i know everyone's been hoping that
they actually include fing fang fume in
some big movie at some point
we never thought that we'd see him but
it seems like the shang chief franchise
is the perfect place to put him
they're also doing the tournament arc a
la enter the dragon with the evil
bondish villain which is obviously the
mcu mandarin in this case
with a vast empire trying to acquire
more power in the one dude
shang chi who has a chance to stop him
with some help from friends that he
makes through the tournament
they've already changed a lot about the
mandarin of the mcu and the 10 rings
through the iron man movies but the
shang chi movie will just
recontextualize
a lot of the stuff that we've seen and
heard about them so far and reveal the
truth of what's been going on
in all those iron man movies these are
all the mandarin references and 10 rings
references that we've had so far
they called themselves the ten rings
you're not him commander the real guy
where you said you wanted the mandarin
[Music]
ten rings are they real it's well
documented
you mean to tell me that
you don't know the history of the
mandarin himself
he was a warrior king inspired
generations of men through the middle
ages
perhaps even further back in time not
the mandarin they'll remember
it's the name trevor slattery you're
right
and for that sin you will soon suffer
horribly with a hole in your body for
every ring of our faith
some of you may remember kevin feige
talking about the mandarin of the mcu
way back i think it was in 2006
it was the year before marvel did their
big iron man panel kevin feige had been
talking about the movie hyping it up
because marvel was getting ready to film
and go into production
he said that the main villain of the
movie would be the mandarin
obviously things did not go down that
way obadiah stain wound up being the
villain of that first iron man film and
kevin feige himself will joke about that
too just explaining how
sometimes during the production process
and development their movies will change
a lot from start to finish
but right now in the mcu canonically the
real mandarin is a warlord who rose to
power
formed the 10 rings organization and
then created several splinter cells
operating independently from the main 10
rings group
throughout history predating most of the
marvel movies in that clip from marvel's
one shot all hail the king when the
reporter is taunting trevor in prison
they're saying some claim that he's
ancient and has lived for centuries
some say he's even older than that wink
wink that's just their way of
acknowledging the comic book mandarin's
backstory
because in the comics the mandarin
started out just as this normal person
a long time ago who found the wreckage
of a crashed alien ship
the alien race were a bunch of big space
dragons and their ship was powered by
the 10 rings
the rings were alive they're sentient
just like thor's hammer is in the comics
they changed their size automatically to
fit his fingers then he went on to use
their power to gain immortality and near
limitless power
the ten rings themselves aren't more
powerful than the infinity gauntlet but
they're sort of an infinity gauntlet
like
story device you can think of them as a
macguffin through the shang chi movie
they're still crazy powerful like near
infinity stone levels of power
such that if the mcu version of the
mandarin ever acquired
all 10 rings he'd be unstoppable for the
most part given that most of the
avengers have disbanded temporarily
and the other more powerful characters
like say captain marvel are busy off in
cree and scroll space dealing with their
own problems way too busy as she says to
come out and help on planet earth
so the shang chi movie is just meant to
dispel all the false myths and tell the
real story of the true mandarin of the
mcu
but even though there probably some
comedic aspects to the film and the
shang chi character like shane chi as a
character himself
does have a good sense of humor i don't
think they'll be playing the real
mcu mandarin for comedy near the way
that they did the trevor character
so in that way i think that most of the
stuff that's been said about the real
mcu mandarin will actually wind up being
true just to make him seem more fearsome
they don't want to turn him into a joke
like trevor
right now the rumor is that aquafina is
actually going to be playing his
daughter in the film and she'll wind up
becoming shang chi's main side piece his
best girl
and will wind up helping him stop her
father from acquiring all
10 rings but at the beginning of the
movie he'll be tasking her with tracking
down the rest of the 10 rings and chiang
chi will just get caught up in the chase
for the 10 rings through the tournament
arc
so if you haven't seen enter the dragon
the villain holds this big mortal combat
like tournament on a private island
every once in a while
it's by invitation only but the prize is
so huge that all the best fighters
around the world go crazy for a chance
to participate
then shang chi just manages to score an
invite to that tournament and uses it an
excuse to try and infiltrate the
mandarin's organization and find out
what's going on with the ten rings
there'll be a ton of iron man easter
eggs as you would expect since the
mandarin is an iron man character
originally but there have been a lot of
rumors about
when the movie takes place in the mcu
timeline they're getting really crazy
with some of these marvel phase 4 movies
like the eternals movie takes place
simultaneously thousands of years ago
because the characters are so ancient
but also in present day after avengers
end game
then you also have stuff like the black
widow movie which takes place
before avengers infinity war but after
captain america civil war so some movies
in marvel phase 4 will be set during
different parts of the timeline and i'll
just explain
where everything fits when we get those
trailers the rumor right now though is
that shang chi actually takes place in
that five-year time gap
after the snap in avengers infinity war
but before avengers end game
the five-year time gap is a really
interesting period in mcu history
because the avengers were fractured even
though some of them were still on planet
earth black widow still trying to keep
the peace with other major heroes left
around the world like in wakanda
but all that chaos around the world
creates a lot of opportunity
for mcu villains to take advantage of
everyone post all your game of thrones
littlefinger memes
chaos is a ladder even though most of
you probably already assumed
marvel and kevin feige have implied that
shang chi would be in avengers 5
they're meant to put him on a new
avengers team when they get ready to
make another one
that movie won't be happening until deep
in marvel phase 5 though so it's still a
long ways off
but most of marvel phase 4 right now is
them introducing
new avengers level characters like kit
harrington's black knight in the
eternals movie
setting the stage for more big cosmic
mcu threats
and even though shane chi is very much a
marvel kung fu action movie a lot of
you're like what is the connection
between say like
shang chi in fantastic four big cosmic
mcu galactus stuff
think about it this way the ten rings of
power are actually
the ten alien rings of power like the
infinity stones wound up on planet earth
there's a very cosmic story behind how
the mcu versions of the ten rings wound
up on planet earth
so that's sort of the backdoor
connection between shang chi
in the space based cosmic marvel movies
so there's going to be a ton of
marvel and spider-man related movies
happening early next year
meaning a ton of big marvel trailers
coming later this year
i know you're all still waiting for a
new falcon and winter soldier trailer
there's also supposed to be
a star wars mandalorian season 2 trailer
sometime in the next couple of weeks
so as long as you have alerts enabled
for my channel you should see all those
videos when i post them
congratulations wes stapley you're the
giveaway winner from my last big marvel
video please email me on the about page
my channel so i can get your contact
details
everyone click here for that brand new
benedict cumberbatch doctor strange 2
clip
and click here to learn about the new
marvel phase 4 movies that they're
bringing thanos back for
thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe i'll see you guys tonight